let's go to Dariel from Texas Daryl from
Texas welcome what's on your mind today
oh hi David uh oh oh hi uh sorry I'm
just kind of nervous okay so my question
it pertains to the debate about like
Trump's indictment and what if it's
gonna help uh uh I just saw a recent
poll from like grass Museum I believe
that shows Biden trailing both Trump and
DeSantis so just so you know rasmussen's
not a good pollster so I tend not to
look at Rasmussen what I would do is
maybe look at an average of recent polls
or look at like the 538 recent polling
and just look at posters rated A and B I
I just don't think rasmussen's a good
pollster but that but it may not matter
for the question you're going towards
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't want to put
a light damage away on a single pole no
but anyways when it comes to like
Trump's indictment yeah uh like like it
could help him in the primary but I
still have a hard time seeing a
Highlander general you know like Trump
he needs like Independence right and
like moderate Republicans you know to
win the general not just a MAG of Base
so my question to you is when it comes
to the indictment what actually went
over like independent and swing voters
or could actually like hurt him in a
general I think in general I don't think
the index so for now we're talking just
about the one indictment right if
there's a different indictment in
Georgia we would have to evaluate the
charges the implications what that's
going to do to Trump's ability to
campaign and then I'll give you an
updated opinion based only on the arrest
and indictment in New York City with the
34 felonies I do believe it helps Trump
in the primary it helps Trump because
nobody's been talking about Ron DeSantis
since the Trump arrest happened and so
publicity Wise It's been better for
Trump than DeSantis I think it has
activated some of Trump's base
um and so I do think Trump has helped in
the primary by this New York City
indictment I don't think it gets him a
single new vote in the general and so
there I think it actually hurts him
oh gosh okay yes yes I was only
wondering because I remember during
during the
during a like the 2016 election like
James Comey like he released a letter on
like Hillary Clinton and and like
Hillary like she was never indicted
never arrested but yet you know but yeah
it didn't help her at all in the general
elections so I'm just here wondering you
know Trump was actually indicted or
arrested yes and is likely to indicted
again in future cases I just have a hard
time you know seeing how people outside
the mag of Base because it has like a w
or good for Trump I agree with you 100
and honestly if they really believed it
was good they'd be less angry and they'd
be happier than they are so I don't buy
it for a second I think your analysis is
spot on
oh gotcha okay uh yes uh like like
that's all I want to ask you like thank
you for taking my call all right Dario
from Texas great to hear from you we're
gonna go to a break I'm sorry I wasn't
able to get to everyone but we will take
calls again back with much more right
after this